way democrats can pass their extreme
radical socialist agenda lie to you
about it
you know the covert bill wasn't about
emergency covert relief infrastructure
bill wasn't about
what they said infrastructure or
everything is now being defined as
infrastructure
their false claims about the georgia
election law were nothing more than an
attempt to smear republicans
bullies finalists corporate cowards to
go along with their lies
senator ted cruz is standing strong
moving ahead with a bill with senator
josh hawley to hold
major league baseball accountable by
moving it to
increase his antitrust scrutiny after
the league
pulled the all-star game from georgia
moved it to colorado
ironically georgia's new law is far more
inclusive than what they have in
colorado or delaware or new york
and with reaction senator cruz senator
i'd be negligent if i didn't ask you
about what's unfolding in minnesota
tonight again and now they have a mayor
talking about
taking away non-lethal alternatives for
police
well obviously what's unfolding in
minnesota is horrific and and the
violence that we're seeing has a
potential to
to spill out and get out of control uh
it it
began with what now appears to be a a
tragic
accident and an accident where where a
man's life was
was taken through a mistake
unfortunately in the course of
interactions with law enforcement
sometimes
there are accidents that occur but but
this is a situation where
the the racial uh powder keg
that we see the left willing to to light
the fire of
and and incite violence and sight
murders that we saw all across the
country murders of police officers
fires and burning of of stores is is is
wrong
and it's horrific the shooting needs to
be fully investigated it needs to be
gotten to the bottom of why that
happened
but the answer is not engaging in
in violent riots and there are a whole
lot of democratic politicians
who celebrate and encourage this kind of
lawlessness
and resort to violence and and it has
become
a a central part of the democratic party
you know i
i want to go to the georgia election law
for this reason i mean the president now
has called it jim crow 2.0
twice he's been in politics over 50
years
georgia's election laws as the reforms
go in place
are much more
accessible to everybody in georgia
than the very rigid laws which we've
gone over in deep detail
for example in joe's state of delaware
now
if he's going to claim jim crow 2.0 in
georgia
why didn't he lift a finger in delaware
and why was he partnering with the
former klansmen to stop the integration
of public schools because he didn't want
them to become racial
jungles as he said look
you're exactly right joe biden
unfortunately has a long history of
engaging in race-baiting
and inciting racial conflict and
divisions
in in a prior election cycle he went
before the naacp and he said
they're going to put you back in chains
which is incendiary
it's a grotesque lie when he accuses
anything he dislikes
of being the new jim crow somehow joe
biden never seems to acknowledge
that jim crow laws were written by
democrats the dixiecrats
were democrats bull connor was a
democrat
the founders of the ku klux klan were
democrats and and you don't have to go
back a hundred years to find that
joe biden a decade ago
gave the eulogy for a grand
cyclops of the ku klux klan robert byrd
the majority
leader of the democratic party joe biden
a decade ago was willing to celebrate
his life
on a vowed klansmen and so the history
of racial bigotry on the democratic side
is horrific
and now the democratic party whenever
they have a political fight
they immediately try to inflame racial
division so with the voting law in
georgia the voting law in georgia is
designed
to protect the right to vote to protect
the integrity of the right to vote
and joe biden and democrats are lying
about it and they know they're lying
about it
but they also know the compliant press
you know i watched the piece you just
did with james o'keefe on cnn
cnn's not going to cover the truth
they're going to repeat the lies
because that's what propaganda outlets
do but
you know it was amazing joe biden's lies
were so bad that the washington post
no right wing organization they are
usually a reliable left-wing mouthpiece
the washington post fact checked joe
biden
on the georgia election law and gave him
four pinocchio said he was flat out
lying
and yet it doesn't stop the democrats
from repeating those lies over and over
again
let me go back to um and what they
really don't want is voter id but they
really don't want a signature
verification
but you need an id for every to buy a
six-pack for crying out loud or to get
in the capital or get in the white house
i want to go back to this violence and
all throughout the summer neither the
media mob
nor the democratic party would even call
riots for what they are
um and they were riots and 3 000 police
officers were hurt and bricks and
bottles and rocks and molotov cocktails
and
and
other injuries yep we had you know 30
people killed over the summer they were
up they shouldn't stop we're not going
to stop uh and beware
on all levels uh that this is going to
continue
i don't i don't hear enough outrage from
democrats now i thought they were
against quote insurrections
there's none whatsoever rasheed talib
the the radical leftist democratic
congresswoman
said in response to what happened in
minnesota we need to
end policing so they're not even hiding
their agendas abolish the police
and by the way if they succeed in doing
that
the people who will be hurt the most are
low-income americans many of them are
african-american many of them are
hispanic
they're the ones that are often the
victims of murder the victims of
violence
but the democrats are willing to do this
to get power
look for example we were just talking
about the georgia voting law
when major league baseball decided to
hypocritically behave like the woke
enforcers for the democratic party
they yanked the all-star game out of
atlanta they moved it to denver
atlanta is 51 percent african-american
denver is nine percent african-american
sean explained to me how a racial social
justice warrior
takes a hundred million dollars out of
atlanta hammers the state of georgia
to move to a state colorado
where they have two fewer days of early
voting than they do in georgia this is
pure politics and they don't care
about all the african-american small
businesses all the african-american
workers
in atlanta that they hurt through their
political gesture
all right senator cruz we thank you for
being with us